this is that first gun I bought for six
on there bucks took the gun and machined
all new top and slide and all this stuff
I made by hand
it says heartbreaker on it I've turned
down over 25 grand for it it like kind
of sparked like wow you know like people
appreciate that kind of hand
craftsmanship this is Jesse James he's
built an empire off of the unlikely
combination of custom motorcycles and
television shows and now he's making
guns I come from South Central LA where
it's like home invasion robberies and
carjacking so like if you don't have a
pump-action shotgun in your house you're
dumb you know you're a dummy Jesse James
firearms unlimited with the cheeky
acronym JJ fu follows a string of
lucrative businesses arguably much of
Jesse's success has come from marketing
his unique personality he's a biker with
pay up sucker tattooed on the palm of
his hand
but he's also disarmingly friendly and
straightforward when I first contacted
JJ after you about coming down to the
workshop in Austin I expected the usual
endless back-and-forth with PR people
instead Jesse personally sent me this
five word email come on dogs Jesse takes
popular gun models like the ar-15 and
the 1911 but recreates them in his own
personal style a style that he tries to
make timeless it's easy to do stuff
that's in the now you know put skulls
and barbed wire all over it and make it
trendy but like when you put it in your
safe and then pull it out in 15 years
you're gonna be like what was I thinking
that looks terrible
Jesse isn't just managing a shop he's
spending hours in front of his Forge
every day doing some pretty advanced
metalwork
for instance the wood like pattern on
this pistol isn't a paint job it's
called the Mascis steel and it takes
about three days for him to make a
single piece Damascus is basically the
same type of material they used to make
samurai swords out of you just pour jit
and cut it and then fold it over and
then two then four this is 450 layers so
you can imagine the tying how time
consuming it is super labor-intensive
for like a cool effect
[Music]
2010 I had a shop and 200 employees a
completely vertical manufacturing I was
miserable sometimes bigger and more
money and more responsibility and more
boat that's not success the elephant in
the room with that time in Jesse's life
this is very public divorce with actress
Sandra Bullock he became a pariah in LA
and ended up making a fresh start in
Austin inspired by an experience he'd
had a year earlier in 2009 I went to
Israel and lived on a kibbutz an
apprentice to be a blacksmith with the
best like traditional blacksmith in the
world a man named Yuri javi and then
just started reconnecting with my
hands-on work again I'm gonna be 45 you
start thinking about your own mortality
and like what is your legacy it's
between actual success that you can hold
in your hand and touch or perceive
success which is like oh I sold so many
stocks oh really big deal you know
craftsmanship is the legacy that'll last
forever
you